him running again in one more year from
now there's no way how Newsome is coming
up and trying to run
um there are other people that are
circling I don't think he runs again I
can't see it I don't see it how do you
think they get Kamala Harris's tip down
because she's rightfully if he steps
down you know until some if Kamala
Harris cannot say a sentence it's almost
she's almost worse than him she talks in
like Gypsy curses
when they ask her something she'll be
like my grandma said that a half a bees
is still bees if you if you bury it and
you're like what the [__] is this [__]
saying Gypsy curtains that's how she
speaks the woman is it has no idea
what's going on but again Washington
inside they're just like you were a D.A
you were a cop you'll keep your mouth
shut don't you want to be the first
whatever race you're pretending to be
president today Indian black whatever
works and she goes yeah
um but they got to get rid of her they
got to get rid of her what they should
have done if they wanted to win George
Soros should have backed up the money
truck to Michelle Obama and said listen
you are going to run because people like
you
they like you it doesn't matter you know
about any of the conspiracies maybe you
are Big Mike who cares what but you are
gonna run this goddamn I believe you
went there you're gonna run this goddamn
country that is the wackiest conspiracy
it's a wacky conspiracy can I make one
point for the people that are on the
side of it yes it is weird but I don't
think she's Big Mike okay
it is weird the [__] that there's not
one photo of her pregnant but maybe
there is is that not weird
maybe it's not weird I don't know he's a
public person why would you want photos
of her pregnant out there I understand
that but it's I just maybe it is weird
maybe it's not weird
maybe it's not weird well also when she
had her kids
were they private or public like when
was that when he was a senator
I don't know I just know that he was a
Senator right yes before he became for
sure
I have no issue because I want to live I
have no issue with Big Mike I don't care
that they killed that sex slave in
Martha's Vineyard that's what happens to
sex slaves they drown in ponds that's
what happens you [__] a ruling class
you try on a pond that's what happens if
you get your little mouthy you go into
the pond
um
I don't have a problem with it I have no
Pro I think it's good I actually think
it's good I think it makes our country
fun I think it makes us unique I think
Putin and them are scared of that [__]
they do it all the time I think Putin
and the Chinese are like you know they
you don't know what's going on there
because they're we got they got people
that maybe they're men maybe they went
we don't know I think if it's not real
make it real
put it out would it would be anything
better than hurt the DNC whip her [__]
out and go and I'm Big Mike the Chinese
would lose their mind the Chinese would
give up they would give up
if Michelle Obama took her [__] out at
the Democratic National Convention the
Chinese would go were thrown in the
towel we can't compete with them
that's why I'm just saying I'm just
saying oh my God
maybe I won't run for governor of
California I don't think you can anymore
maybe it's a bad idea yeah not that
state it's not a great idea but I bet
you get in like Wyoming yeah
get yourself a nice spread yeah I could
definitely become the governor of
Wyoming there's definitely a small town
that would elect me mayor 100 100 100
yeah